[Music]
all right huge breaking news tonight now
we've been telling you it's coming it is
now here
stunning reporting tonight from Sarah
Carter that we are confirming with our
sources classified DOJ documents that
members of Congress are now reviewing it
shows widespread and extensive FISA
abuses against the Trump campaign and we
have names now here's how it all went
down at the last minute the house they
finally got literally within an hour
their subpoena request approved by the
DOJ members of Congress were able to get
their hands on all these classified
documents that what the last minute rod
Rosenstein tried to stop it by going in
a Paul Ryan's office Paul Ryan would
have none of it now it is more
disturbing than we ever thought and at
this hour our sources are telling us
that the abusive power is far bigger
than Watergate remember Watergate was a
third-rate break-in what we're talking
about tonight is the systematic abuse of
power
the weaponizing of those powerful tools
of intelligence and the shredding of our
Fourth Amendment constitutional rights
that protect all of us against unlawful
search and seizure it is complicated but
it's also simple we're going to break it
all down for you in a way I hope that's
easy to understand now go back to the
Watergate comparison for a minute you
got a group of people who tried to cover
up the lead up to an election they broke
in the stole things they shouldn't have
stole from the opposition what we're
talking about tonight is an abuse of the
powerful tools of intelligence that we
used to spy on people except those tools
were used against an opposition
candidate and a president-elect and his
entire team and it was done not only
under false pretenses but with the help
of Hillary Clinton she bought and paid
for the dossier that they filled with
Russian lies propaganda salacious
details that were never true and that
dossier was corroborated we now know by
a long-term longtime Clinton ally and
sycophant now here are the people that
we're going to learn an awful lot about
in the next couple of weeks pay very
close attention
they are the highest ranks of the
Department of Justice in your FBI and
today we can confirm that the Trump
hating Clinton loving FBI agent Peter
struck and his mistress FBI lawyer Lisa
Paige they are at the Nexus of
everything and there's so much more
information coming now at the end of all
of this we're gonna learn an awful lot
beyond any shadow of a doubt that the
Special Counsel Robert Muller and his
band of democratic witch hunters never
should have been appointed and they need
to be disbanded immediately now here's
why struck and Paige are connected to
everything what we're learning tonight
is that these two Trump aiding
individuals they're at the heart and
soul and center of it all remember we
still have 9600 texts of theirs between
each other that we haven't seen yet and
we're expecting that some of them will
be released tomorrow and everything that
we've learned so far about struck and
Paige is now beginning to make sense let
me explain they call Trump an idiot
alone some human and said F Trump and by
the way the meeting behind this
particular text message is now tonight
coming into clear focus
remember struck he wrote his mistress
page I want to believe the path that you
threw out for consideration in Andy's
office that there's no way he gets
elected but I'm afraid we can't take
that risk
it's like an insurance policy in the
unlikely event you die before you're 40
now we believe here at Fox that Andy
mentioned in that text is the FBI deputy
director Andrew McCabe and this text
message was sent on August the 15th of
2016 this is a very critical time frame
and here's why around the exact same
time that struck in Paige are talking
about their insurance policy
well the Obama administration officials
are going to the FISA Court to get a
warrant on Carter Paige stay with me
they're using quarter-page as a pretext
to really spy on the Trump campaign and
now it is transparent to all of us what
struck was saying to Paige when they
spoke about the insurance policy with
Andy we believe Andrew McCabe and that
text message needing that of insurance
policy now everyone seems to forget lisa
Paige is a key legal counselor
for mccabe see how it all ties together
and listen when they're sending the text
messages about an insurance policy
they're also going to the FISA Court now
sources are telling us tonight that the
first time they tried to get the FISA
warrant against Carter Paige was in the
summer it was denied then the second
time they tried to get it in the early
fall they used the phony Clinton bought
and paid for dossier and this time they
were successful for one reason the fake
news dossier put the request over the
top it was the final nail on the coffin
to get the FISA warrant out there
against Trump now you can forget about
the reporting about george papadapolis
running his mouth at a nightclub to an
australian diplomat any lawyers going to
tell you that that four-way here say
it's never going to hold up in court
hearsay doesn't hold up in court so back
to Carter page and the FISA warrant on
him is a very important variety of
things happening here at that point the
Obama administration they should have
known that the dossier was totally false
full of salacious Russian lies it should
have been suspect on its face value
now fusion GPS they never even verified
what was in that dossier never tried
because they trusted Christopher Steele
who they hired who put it all together
the same Christopher Steele would
reportedly you know pay Russians to get
information and by his very nature think
about it is a former mi6 guy he was
highly skilled in deception so tonight
sources who are familiar with this
classified information only Congress can
see it right now they are telling me
that it's a case of show me the man and
I'll show you the crime all right now
they are up to speed on that part we
have a lot of questions for key people
involved now we need to know what all of
these top Obama administration officials
knew and when they found out and exactly
how they were involved in spying on an
opposition campaign and an incoming
president now our questions don't end
there what did Hillary Clinton know her
campaign no the DNC that she controlled
no we know they paid fusion gps what 12
million plus dollars to put this phony
dossier together did she know this was
happening and when did she know it what
President Obama no was he briefed about
the dossier before the election we
believe he was to sum it all up clinton
fixed the primary remember against
Bernie Sanders then Peter struck in
James Comey well they fixed the
investigation into her emails by
exonerating her before even
investigating that particular case that
allowed Clinton to stay in the race and
at the same time struck his mistress
Lisa page deputy FBI director McCabe
seemed to be on a mission an insurance
policy mission to destroy Trump
insurance policies in case god forbid he
wins we don't think it's going to happen
and it's clear they were using the
powerful tools of intelligence and a
FISA warrant to have a back-up plan in
case Hillary lost this is far worse than
Watergate this is an abuse of
surveillance and intelligence to win an
election
a massive abuse of power and it was all
done by just a few people who think and
thought they knew better than you about
who should be the president of the
United States and this is only the tip
of the spear it is the biggest national
scandal by far in our lifetime